Now this person who asked this question, I'm going to read the question. I did not include their
first part of their question because quite honestly it wasn't, it wasn't understandable.
So I just would ask that they just try to take more care and formulating their questions so
I can understand what you're asking. They said this through the member site
which, okay let me just answer the question. I have been doing B17 which I have been
crecied to two IVs next week. So this person is doing B17 IVs I believe. So this person is not
doing really any nutritional protocol from me. So they are doing that. I believe they're using the
right. I'm not even positive about that. I've heard much from this person. I'm all, I also am
highly contemplated using the starting the Fedendezole and I've erected. So just looking for advice,
I have some I've erected but my source went out of business. So I would need to do source and I'm
not sure where to get the Fedendezole. Okay so if you have access to the member site which you do
the whole protocol for Fedendezole and I've erected is right on the first page of the member site
including link, a link to purchase the Fedendezole. We sell the Fedendezole. The IV erected I can't legally
give you information and where to buy it. So you'll let to find your source of IV erected I can't
help you with that. But the Fedendezole is legal to purchase. We sell that on our store and then as
far as advice for that you can certainly make an appointment with me so we can have a call but
I don't know that you need to because all the entire protocol for Fedendezole and I've erected is
on the the member site and then I've we've had this question come up probably 50 times or I probably
have at least 20 videos on this as well. So make sure you look at that as well.
I understand that the difficulty with using IV erected is trying to find a source where you're
going to be able to get the right dosage and that's always a little bit of a struggle but I think that
we have enough people that are on IV erected that they haven't had a problem finding it. Now remember
your dose of IV erected you have to convert your body weight from pounds to kilograms and the dose
for IV erected for cancer is one half milligram per kilogram of body weight so let's say you weigh
50 kilograms per 10. So your dose would be 25 kilograms of IV erected per day that would be your
starting dose. And then depending on how bad your cancer is and how fast it's progressing you
move up in your dose of IV erected from from one half milligram per kilogram to one milligram per kilogram
and we have some people taking two milligrams per kilogram. Fedendezole is a little bit different.
The the recommendation for Fedendezole is all over the place. I know Dr.
Mackis recommends fairly high dose Fedendezole because he's mainly dealing with people that are
late late late stage cancer and he's trying to hit it really hard quickly. The Joe Tippen's original
Fedendezole protocol only called for 22 milligrams three days a week four days off but literally the
protocol is people are doing all sorts of different things with Fedendezole. Some people are taking
that original dose of 222 milligrams just daily. Some people are taking four times that much
daily. Some people are taking two packets of Fedendezole. So 444 milligrams four days a week or three
days a week and then three days off. There's benefits to pulsing it on and off like three days on
four days off or four days on three days off or something like that because Fedendezole
has a tendency to do some damage to the liver so you do need to keep an eye on your liver markers,
your alkaline phosphates, your ast and ALT. You do need to keep an eye on those because about 50%
of the people end up having liver disruption from Fedendezole. We haven't really seen that with
Ivermacted but Fedendezole is the nasty one of your liver.